wow
what's so cool about the marketing with
this in particular is that with the
t-shirts having like a blueprint design
of like the early stages of developing
all this and having notes on it it kind
of makes you think about online
marketing viral videos just for films
but instead of doing that they're doing
that with their merch what's happening
spider-man fans we got ourselves a
spider-man no way home 2021 promo art
reveals new secrets gonna be watching
this from our buddy chris over at 3c
films subscribe to his channel if you
haven't done so already reliable source
killing it these days chrissy
[Music]
man come on where the hell is he was
supposed to be here with this trailer
hey everyone had to beat an old lady
with a stick to get this trailer all
right we'll go ahead and sit down toby
everything's set up here let's go ahead
and hit play on that trailer that's
weird i wasn't expecting
[Laughter]
is that the old lady that was for real
you actually beat her up i'm gonna put
some dirt in your eye
[Music]
see your chumps
hello spiderman chris has lost mine
absolutely
bonkers intro yet
because we are finally getting some more
crumbs still no trailer that's still
hidden deep down in the depths of bully
mcguire's closet so until him or kevin
pagoli decides to release this trailer
this is all we got to stare at and you
know what is some pretty cool stuff
because it reveals some interesting
details about spider-man no way but
specifically what we're going to be
talking about here today guys is we got
a whole bunch of merchandise that has
landed online for spider-man no way home
mainly t-shirt designs and when i say a
whole bunch i mean a whole bunch of
t-shirts
have been released we're going to be
bringing that down along with a couple
other we got some shirts to buy yep
first footage for that shirt every week
why not go public so be sure you guys
leave me your opinions with everything
we discussed here today let me know
which one is your favorite t-shirt
design why do you think we have still
not gotten the damn trailer for
spider-man no way home as well as don't
be forgetting to hit that like button
and subscribe if you want more great
movie related content headed your way
alright so this all came late in the
afternoon yesterday when somebody went
ahead and realized that spider-man no
way home merch showed up on amazon i'm
sure it's a daily thing for somebody out
there who is just constantly searching
up spider-man no way home on amazon
until something magical comes up because
a few days ago we had this children's
book that showed up that said spider-man
and it's a very strange day which is a
little children's tie-in book that'll be
released in november in promotion with
the movie the plot along with the book
didn't really give us anything that
looks adorable and we didn't get to see
any of the inside pages but still it's
the crumbs the fans are desperate for
because we have not gotten a trailer so
you damn well bet i hate that book
but i guess lately afternoon yesterday
somebody went ahead and did their daily
amazon spider-man no way home digging
and found a couple of t-shirt designs
some of the first ones that came out
cool
just strange this kind of reminds me of
a famous comic book cover in the
spider-man world but again it's just
really in promoting that spider-man
doctor stranger part of this movie then
we had another one of them side by side
really am liking the design here of the
black and gold suit the doctor strange
spidey emblem on his chest i'm still
curious if this is gonna play out in the
movie because i'm a pure spidey fan and
i really do like me the classic looking
costume i'm trying to keep an open mind
here and remain positive with this and
hope that it makes sense the more that
these images come out and even with that
leaked set photo it just seems to be
confirming that doctor strange is gonna
be more than just like a scene or two it
really seems like he's gonna be the main
supporting character more than what even
iron man was in spider-man homecoming oh
yeah it looks like they're gonna have to
take this situation and confront it
together it looks like well spider-man's
handling one part of it doctor strange
is gonna be handling a whole bunch of
other parts of it and as much as we are
excited for the multiverse angle of it
all the way the promos have been i've
been feeling like spider-man and doctor
strange adventures yeah yeah
we also got another one of doctor
strange's spider-man jumping
there
this is also i believe our first piece
of science that has spider-man in his
upgraded suit compared to the one that
he was given in far from home again the
main difference with this suit and the
one from far from home is that in
spider-man no way home they got rid of
the black strips on the belt and to me
that gives it a much cleaner look on
this suit and is the suit i wish he just
had for the entirety of the movie
probably the one that had me a little
hyped up before people started finding a
lot more spider-man t-shirts out there
oh that's a dope shirt spider-man peter
parker a menace because everybody knows
peter parker is spider-man
that's my favorite one so far to see
this storyline play out in spider-man no
way home because last we saw him in
spider-man far from home everybody knows
his identity thanks to mysterio and here
we kind of get a good idea of how the
public is branding peter parker that's
my favorite one so far for sure so
you're calling dibs is what you're
saying yeah and what not we also get to
see in the background we have the new
iron spider suit which another t-shirt
i'm going to show to you guys here kind
of gives us some more details about this
certain iron spider suit but it was just
those couple of t-shirt designs people
found at first where we were like okay
this cool some nice little crumbs
something to get us excited on to the
next day until the floodgate of
spiderman t-shirts started drowning in
my bank account people that went ahead
and started searching spider-man no way
home on a bunch of different retailers
wow
bunch of spiderman t-shirts they're
already on sale in promotion with the
movie then they did it with box lunch
basically anywhere you can buy a t-shirt
for some reason marvel was like all
right you can release your spider-man no
way home merch we ain't releasing that
trailer y'all it's crazy how this is
becoming the advertisement for it how
much leaks and merch and toy leaks and
all that stuff can we keep getting
before we get this damn trailer i know
has there been a movie like this where
this has happened to this degree and did
endgame go through this cycle i didn't
track it as much
that i can think of no i mean like i
feel like i remember we heard like maybe
one or two toy leaks you know in a cycle
but this is like constantly with toys
and now t-shirt designs and the t-shirts
almost seem not that like the toys
aren't credible but like yeah like that
marvel would know like yeah go ahead and
release the t-shirts you know we'll just
use that as free advertising as we move
into our final you know process of
putting out the trailer for real you
know like at this point yeah it could be
like a new marketing strategy basically
they need to start putting that trailer
out because like i was misled by the way
how suicide squad was like so hyped on
the internet was trending all weekend
top ten yeah then it come out it's a box
office flop zeitgeist i live in i'm like
smarter man i know i hope it's gonna be
like a 2 billion movie
of all time i know it's not a direct
comparison at all like spider-man is a
much bigger ip i totally get it and
built in the mc so like i totally know
it's just i think they need a trailer by
now right yeah at this point because
like there's gonna be an actu a massive
spoiler in one of these at some point so
there are literally like a hundred
different t-shirt designs but i'm gonna
try to be sticking to the ones that have
the most information and seem relevant
to the movie so one really cool one that
caught my eye here is again of the black
and gold
where is that
look at that
strange powers again very hesitant how
this will work but even with the
irritation i really do like the visual
effects that are put even on just this
t-shirt also it kind of looks like this
black and gold suit isn't all black and
gold because on the side of spider-man
he's looking a little blue there that
might just be from the visual effect
here and him throwing out this light up
blue web that is giving him this kind of
blue hue honoring electro
it's also curious to see why this web
shooter is on the other side of his
wrist than on the back side like it
usually is a lot of theories to why
spider-man would need doctor strange
powers in spider-man no way at home
still unclear especially with other
t-shirts like this that we got to say
science plus magic which is letting you
know that this suit is a combination of
tony stark technology or a new suit that
peter parker made using tony stark
technology and then that got upgraded
and enhanced with some doctor strange
abilities mainly those web shooters i
gotta think those web shooters are for
sure dr strange enchanted things one
t-shirt here that we look at is actually
a match wow
avengers infinity war and that's him
again with the black and gold suit
shooting a web but this time it's
written as magic with a thw now thrip is
sometimes the sound effect used in the
comic books when spider-man is shooting
out a web just to give a reader an idea
of what it sounds like when spider-man
is spelled
if you go back to avengers infinity war
when he's all right i'm not sure if i
trust this design
portals to fight him he starts saying
things like
magic
just nice
[Music]
interesting t-shirt design that gives us
a better idea of what's going on with
one of the newer suits in spiderman no
way home is this one right here of the
new iron spider suit now again i like to
say that i like this version of the iron
spider suit way better than the previous
version and here we kind of get an idea
of why it looks slightly different than
the last one here off to the side it
says iron spider suit plus red and black
suit which confirmed a lot of people's
theories that if you do remember in
avengers infinity war when spider-man is
heading off up into space he's starting
to lose air and he's about to pass out
tony stark sends in the nanotech that
would go ahead and cover spiderman and
give him his our spider suit well now we
know that nanotech is meant to blend in
with whatever suit he's wearing so i
assume now because he has the upgraded
and is not going to be going back to the
classic suit whenever that nanotech
attaches to spider-man this time it's
gonna blend in with his current suit and
just give him that gold but keep the red
and black instead of some of the blue
like we were seeing in the infinity war
suit i like that right there again i'm
just wondering how they're gonna explain
spider-man using all these different
suits in the movie it's all stuff that
i'm like this is gonna take way too much
time in the movie to explain what's so
cool about the marketing with this in
particular is that with the t-shirts
having like a blueprint design of like
the early stages of developing all this
and having notes on it it kind of makes
you think about online marketing viral
videos just for films but instead of
doing that they're doing that with their
merch clueing you in putting you more
into the world itself but through the
merchandise versus like an online
marketing video you know what i mean
yeah it almost seems like a really
clever way of saving a bunch of money
while also giving us something that is
still really visual and that people are
going to want to buy instead of just
watch on repeat exactly you know i'm
loving the way it's all looking that
nano tech though i'm kind of wondering
it because i i don't really remember i
don't think he did it far from home but
if he has the suit here that means he
can kind of just walk around as peter
parker and be able to activate a nano
tech spider-man device the way how i
robert downey jr did that in avengers
infinity war yeah i would guess so an
end game yeah long as he's got you know
his clothes or whatever so he would have
like a nano tech spider-man suit that he
could just have like regular clothes
zombie in high school and he could leave
instead of like changing into it yeah he
could just have a nano attack one that'd
be cool really convenient tony we also
got other t-shirts here that again are
playing in promotion with that whole
thing that new york city and we believe
it's mysterious divided on whether
spider-man is a menace or he's actually
innocent so we do have some we believe
mysterio t-shirts that started showing
up along with some shirts that look like
they were definitely made by spider-man
fans in the spider-man universe where
has this classified signal
you rock peter parker wouldn't be
surprised if flash thompson is the one
who made this t-shirt oh my god yeah
we currently have going on right now
guys i want to thank so much for taking
the time to watch this video let me know
what you guys thought of these t-shirt
designs do you have a favorite one are
there any things you can pick out from
this stuff that i didn't catch really
love to hear from you guys i already
declare which one's my favorite
which one am i gonna buy after this as
always i'm chris take care
thank you chris that was awesome that
was awesome and i love all your little
inserts you did in this video man your
editing game is up and guys subscribe to
36 films we haven't done so already
which t-shirt design here do you think
is your personal favorite subscribe to
us click that notification bell it's
nice to get some official
spider-man things released from the
actual people involved in the spider-man
making of yes whether that's marketing
or not you know you know what i'm trying
to say guys
fluff doran
john flev my dude i want you to become
the next spider-man villain that's my
thing linking people to movies and
imagine you you have such an insane like
the rock that's my thing
people that are making people's movies
i'm gonna do my eyebrow thing and i'm
gonna elect you really nicely with
machismo and intimidation in my heart
because flav i want you to be quivering
in your boots i don't know what the the
problem is i gotta go here patrick
warburton
left doran listen up buddy we love you
over here at the real rejects and now
i'm gonna do it's john benjamin
listen we we love you buddy and we love
your uh your enthusiasm i got right i
gotta watch an episode of archer again
because i feel like my timbre is all off
with this guy oh it's good thank you uh
you know left door and [ __ ] look this
is the only thing of aaron paul i know
how to do all right so uh thanks for
your complete buddy thank you love you
[Music]
you